welcome to Japan World Cup - the most
important race of your life
it's this excess DVD I bought online it
looks even more weird than the first one
so for those of you are very confused
that will not change throughout this
entire video but basically it's a
raising game and we're gonna bet who's
gonna win all right
you bros really wanted me to do the
other one and I was gonna do it anyway
there we go hyung imagine you man I
still can't find subtitles for the
trucking video it's so confusing I
unique I jump on Waldo Cup Japan Nevada
caffeine Akari the hot on you I can love
the regulation sebastian michaelis sekai
de motu you must feel like a father
Minooka feel like a proud father
Luxembourg oh god I don't know the flag
ichiba gee sorry boy knee pop alright
Japan is back Bangladesh that knee boom
Na Hoku is back with his weird-ass
[ __ ] dance moves
he France looks [ __ ] as ever but the
[ __ ] Branson a local Elvis nipple is
blonde man and talking Patricia Miyagi
the coach Oh interesting
under that I thought not loading Lynch's
hair I suppose a check ok America's back
I don't see much difference here like
you suck now so I will see what tricks
they have up their sleeves Oh what the
papa China China of course look from
Hong Kong is not a horse man you know
that not a moment Chloe so [ __ ] Panda
New Zealand booster all those tiny
ponies chica even if the New Zealander
is a [ __ ] tiny person checking out a
little part it's a baby kuru king jr
okay that is most definitely not a horse
yeah yeah Carlton I am like with it 95%
sure that's not a horse hey this back
yes it's a barrel do nothing you are
yeah see how I love a badge or not NATO
cannon
I will have to go where that number one
and they're up all right it looks like
America has a strong start very very
strong start shortly after his Elvis and
Franz isn't right on the tail I think
even pink rambunctious thereafter Oh
Japan is actually number four oh these
using the move I know that move that
move is [ __ ] amazing how is that horse
still in the race
China's after come man you let me in I
don't know the name of that country he
don't know uh
Kenny I don't know I sank on this but I
do know number eight is gonna fall at
this curve your barge on that border
famous this is a con kind of concepts
America do it don't fall god damn it god
[ __ ] damn it just America soon you're
we're dance simply think how do you
thirty minutes can be anyone's race at
this point somebody's bound to make a
move soon you know someone's gonna make
a move Clara des bronze is sugar
whipping [ __ ] put on phone oh I knew
they are this could be anyone's raise at
this point I credit our America how do
the imaging whatever what's gonna happen
agreement I remember Peter
Corrado
Oh Elvis got his movie Elvis got this
one what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he's
charting the elephant oh oh
holy [ __ ] the [ __ ] spin man I'm gonna
have to go with Franz unless you kill a
young buck I mean you're gonna have to
go with Franz I think Francis is sore
loser and there she will start stripping
or some [ __ ] America strolling start
again that's kind of each King card I
wish me right after we do some bunch of
Cinnabon tawheed it's literally the same
thing every single [ __ ] time come on
don't [ __ ] fall I swear to God if the
barrel horse fall every time barrel
horse the elephant is doing air guitar
or Honda what the [ __ ] is fun to do in
China China shoot [ __ ] barrel rolls
holy [ __ ] is it enough to keep him in
the go loading the Chinese candy do it I
think the cookies no no Elvis has got a
car I'm pretty sure that's illegal
I know what tiny words this Elvis move
what the [ __ ] just happened
mom oh c'mon Mikey Trainor Elvis did it
okay you know if horse-racing was like
this I'd probably actually watch it now
is barrel eight gonna make the curve
come on eh come on eight I believe it
you God but who is no Palestine barrel
roll
oh [ __ ] elephant is going crazy I mean
horse the jumper horse
holy [ __ ] Oh
deep red ha ha ha ha
jumbo [ __ ] you looking at ok jumbo LM a
mean horse in a jump horse edit jumpin
I'm drown you took anyway I don't think
anyone saw that coming because any was
raised what is the baby the baby is
running in the air and it seems to be
working
Elvis got his [ __ ] weird ass [ __ ]
thing but I don't think I always got
this one
the horse is stretching a little bit
isn't it Oh what it's always doing I
don't know what to call that
what the [ __ ] is going oh [ __ ] it sharks
itself up to that far away
that's amazing holy [ __ ] rocket horse
race number five I think I should change
from prawns cuz prawns doesn't seem to
[ __ ] be doing it this time I'll go
with baby on this one come on baby
bleedin how do you come on baby boom I
can tell you volume up do you mind just
remember I don't know [ __ ] this is
really [ __ ] tight what's gonna have
everything frogs get this one prizes in
the lead Oh Ross is tripping I knew it
god [ __ ] damn it right when I changed
what that mean come on later
Corina Clementina Japan so Tonga hasn't
won yet baby hasn't won yet and Paige
has a Mayan I wonder if n is gonna do
like the recovery like it at any first
first round
I think it's baby or punt at this point
I'm gonna have to go with Panda I'm
changing mid-race yes you can do that
come on Panda ha
do the barrel do a barrel oh [ __ ] baby
is writing pon de I'm pretty sure though
it's writing elephant it's dancing with
the Americans and it jumps into the gold
holy [ __ ] that slide [ __ ] baby
[ __ ] New Zealanders man comment on it
I don't like how he stares into the
camera I don't come in recently no stop
okay well that means I'm going to bet my
left testicle uh that Panda is gonna win
this one
I'm gonna be so surprised if Honda does
not win this one
I am so emotionally invested in this
weirdest [ __ ] Japanese racing game it
is kind of ridiculous what the [ __ ] are
you doing Japan that is not how you're
right points everyone is [ __ ] weird
jump run away I don't mean skin tone
okay time Onimusha with a girl fighting
she said I'm on meditated honking what
the [ __ ] ever to China to happen to the
partner what the [ __ ]
oh god it's breaking oh it's super fast
Hong Kong did it oh god that is another
comfortable to ride on Jesus Curtis I'm
so excited
each one you come on boy hey hey hey hey
hey
don't oh please
okay okay that's how you coffee hot
young water come on don't fall
Elvis is really doing well what's gonna
happen
who's gonna win this race it's now or
never it's spinning Japan is spinning my
comment what is he doing it why is
master hate didn't win bunch oh he's
have anyone likes Japan what the [ __ ]
Lisa there's more I'm so confused
that's one of the more races in it I
don't understand what's gonna happen we
think how do you three machines so about
the last one was the last race oh it's
fine it's real time am i sucked up hyena
put it on you see you're set out of the
card okay go home you got hot even get a
stripper girl step sit bumper the 14th a
nice kiss of some time what is going on
what the [ __ ] are they doing why
that's the pride horse that's a fine
horse right there I knew it - away
Hey
Oh Oh it touches me it touches me just
like Steven Collins
now boys
Jeff Burton world cup - I have Japan
world cup three if you want me to do
that one leave a life right now and
leave a comment about horses
dog endured and then I want to thank you
for us
we're always paying from that's it for
me for now and as always stands come on
Japan number three oh geez
he's making us big he's picking up speed
oh god damn it come on